live mainly just going to be trying to
get GPU drive to
be what we'd like it to
be let's
um looks
good uhhuh
and
ooh very
spiky very spiky
indeed oh that's because of the resample
though
okay I think it should be good enough by
200 mil
hopefully we will
see but yeah this is just because of
resample it's like every 5 mil or
something
probably um let's
see I am waiting at the moment to see if
we're going to
have any meeting with uh NYU folks but
in the meantime I'll be here
streaming and it's going to take a
little while for this model to finish
training and to think what to do in the
meanwhile I have this training locally I
guess I could try to get um let's take a
quick look at some of our hyper pram
stuff in the meanwhile maybe be
good so we've got um you know all this
hyper pram work I've been trying to
do and I think we have Connect 4 maybe
done by now let's
see tag just
tag no only 50 one
experiments I mean it's
solved but solved in 200
mil some's weird with that hold on cuz
if we look at
Cost jump to very high cost very
quickly do Paro run on
this yeah no this is not um
you know it's interesting that it's
pushed the cost up that
high it probably shouldn't have done
that oh you know what it
is
um it's that it knows
that it has a good predictive model of
cost because it knows that it's going to
just solve
it
h didn't think about that
we kind of don't bias to lower cost do
we if you think no wait we do we bias to
highest
performance we don't really
bias away from cost really except in
terms of confidence I
suppose well that's new Improvement that
can be made on the algorithm I
suppose I'm not going to mess with it at
the moment because it's already very
good I mean look it
has it has the hyper prems here and we
got this one is very nice you know I
would have liked to have seen this more
in this area here
maybe but yeah that's a little bit of a
quirk if it has too good of a predictive
model it kind of just gets stuck yeah
let push gamma up to Max
oh is there any point in leaving
this I guess there is because it might
try to let's see if it tries to push
cost down on its
own I mean
technically it will resample parito
points but I don't think it's going to
search around the resampled parito
points on its own oh yeah look it's
pushed num Ms all the way to the bottom
okay
so there is a big improvement over carbs
but not quite the god algorithm
yet missing a few a few
things I mean we could try to think
about that in the
meanwhile we could go through the carbs
math a little bit and see if we can
figure out how to do this
I mean I guess I'm going to kind of keep
this as a uh a
puzzle over the next few weeks to see if
I
can see if I can crack
this so here's the
map let's move this to
review all right so we got these Gan
processes
this was originally preventing you
from choosing hyper parameters too far
away from your current set of hyper
parameters um that doesn't really do
anything for me so we got rid of
that we replaced this with a
conservative estimate of absolute
performance so it we've replace it
specifically with
GP y
which is a gaussian process that
estimates that takes in the hyper
parameters you've chosen and estimates
how well it thinks they're going to
do and we've subtracted the variance of
that or the standard deviation of that
to get a conservative estimate of the
performance so this is a local estimate
how well do you think you're going to
improve over the
current and then we
have this term uh not this term we
replace this with the absolute
Improvement
estimate
now because the absolute
estimate is
conservative you get penalized for
trying to explore regions uh for which
the model doesn't have any support So
for which you're likely
to uh you get penalized for exploring
unconfident
regions but we don't actually factor in
cost explicitly it's just that those two
things are
correlated so in fact if you have an
accurate predictive model of
performance if you have an accurate
predictive model of performance then
you're going to get pushed to explore
higher and higher
cost
Solutions no you're going to get Pro to
perform to higher and higher performance
solutions which may or may not be higher
cost but there's no term that's trying
to pull you towards lower
cost
right so that's a bit of a
problem because there's a little bit of
a balance to this thing right you know
you don't want to be you don't want to
not explore high cost stuff when it's
needed
but you also want to try to find the
most efficient
solution what can we do mathematically
to represent
that we have estimates of
cost we have estimates of
performance how do we mathematically
Express that we want
to we want the highest
performing lowest cost
solution we can simplify a little bit in
the sense that some environments you
know we can just solve the environment
uh and in that case you know there is a
hard cap on the
score you know it's a little tricky
because all the scores have different
magnitudes so there's no way for us to
express you know how much perform like
how much score we're willing to trade
for a faster
solution I mean okay one version of this
is just that we want to explore the
entire parito front
right well let's think about
that this
term is evenly weighted across the Paro
front
term is likely going to be biased
towards the higher cost
regions not this term the one that we
replace this term with
what happens if instead of multiplying
the two
terms we just do one half the time in
the other or the other half the
time so one of these will be evenly
sampled on the Pito
front and the other is absolute highest
performance that still doesn't really
cap what I want you know the opt like
the best hyperparameter algorithm should
be able to view its
experiments as a budget right it's
spending a specific amount of compute to
run each
experiment and it should be trying to
maximize the results over the
entire
results we don't just mean find the
absolute highest performing point right
that's always going to be almost always
going to be the most expensive
point we really do want the entire Paro
front you know this term here or this
the absolute term pushes you towards
higher cost cost it pushes you to higher
cost slowly
conservatively but that's what it does
I mean one half the time the other half
the time isn't
bad there should be some mathematical
formalism that allows you to formulate
your like you want to be able to
formulate your experiments as a
budget now let's ask Claud I don't think
that I'm missing anything
obvious I don't like no maap like
there's no specific math that comes to
mind
here but let me see if I can formalize
this
so
POS have
welcome YouTube folks we're just doing a
little bit of stuff on neoc carbs the
new hyper pram sweep algorithm while I'm
waiting for this GPU driving Sim
experiment to finish up
here um I'm trying to reformulate this a
little bit I I think that there's a math
that might exist for this what I'm
trying to do but it doesn't come to mind
I'm trying to see if I can find a
is your goal to discover the parito
front
or is your goal to
discover a specific set of
parameters your goal is probably to
discover the Pito front and the reason
for this is that you don't know the
shape of the Pito front right very often
the Pito front is very sharp so you just
pick the corner point right but it could
be sort of
smoother in which case you can kind of
get the uh the parameters you want for
your cost do a lot of analysis there
let's see if there's anything obvious
that I've
missed I don't think there's anything
like super obvious like oh just use you
know this specific
model welcome YouTube folks
that's kind of cool viewership is kind
of gone nicely back
up I'm going to try to be streaming a
lot more now um I got a small trip lined
up for next week but other than that I'm
pretty much just streaming all my
Dev and all the
research so let me see what this is
so acquisition
function divided by compute cost of
evaluation see that's not a
good function I don't
think wait hold on it's
estimated well estimated
Improvement divided by
cost okay so the thing that's tricky
here
is that this is improvement over your
model of cost this is not actual
improvement over your existing hyper
parameters so I got stuck on this before
because if you replace uh if you replace
this with like improvement over your
existing hyper parameters you just keep
shifting up to higher and higher compute
um and that kind of just goes on
forever but you know what we could do
what if we used
instead of using your existing parito
Point what if we did nearest
cost then what would that do that would
give you
point wait wait let me see did this this
actually just do it hold on estimate
uh
weights cost by
estimated the cost at specific point
regardless whe this
yeah the other thing we could do is we
could use a conservative estimate of
cost cost Minus cost
variance no that's bad because that
gives
you if you do Cost Plus cost variance
that's even
worse that just pushes you away from
high cost regions
here this is just going to push you very
far away from high clost I
think let me see if I can develop this a
little bit
more let me move this so I can see the
chat as well and how far are we on this
okay 26 minutes uh I can probably even
eval what
the oh it's just doing the uh it's fine
it's a noisy estimate um that's fine
so so the problem with using the
estimate
right these are both scoring functions
they're not
generative so this doesn't actually tell
you the optimal hyper parameters at a
specific
cool but that would just give you like a
a single estimate
maybe can you have a gaan process on
multiple
interesting the reason for the gan
process is that they give you um they
give you this nice estimate of
I don't know if this is a good idea to
be honest
H this is too big of a change to be
exploring at the moment I think
I think the other thing I was on was
better so let me go back and just
finally formalize this so the goal is
that a key problem with carbs is it
develops a model of the Pito front but
it's not really incentivized to actually
like fill in the model of the Paro front
to check it properly
because you get
um you have basically these two
competing gaussian processes where one
says how good how good can you do with a
set of hyper parameters and the other
says what's the best you could do with
any set of hyper parameters and the only
time you really sample stuff is when you
think uh that you can do better than
your best set of hyper parameters right
uh the best set of hyper parameters but
basically if you have a op optimal uh
prediction of hyper
parameters actually let me think if you
have an optimal set of hyper parameters
then uh this term where is
it then this term goes to zero so ignore
P search we got rid of that this term
goes to zero and you sample uniformly
across the pero
front which is actually good that's what
you want
so you're incentivized to make progress
evenly across the Pito front really
we already tried making this estimate
conservative and it was
worse I like the idea of a conservative
estimate because it kind of it it means
that your experiments um you're going to
make them where you're very
confident that you can
improve but the thing is that hampers
your exploration
ation hampers your exploration because
you don't go to uh new regions you kind
of stick too close to existing hyper
parameters and then we got the absolute
term which pushes you towards regions of
high performance as your predictive
model gets better and we're currently
we're multiplying those
two the problem with multiplying those
two terms is that you do get pushed
to regions of higher
cost as soon as your predictive model
gets
good but you don't just want regions of
higher cost you really want to fill in
the entire Paro front
and also this doesn't fill in the Pito
front right this only fills
in this only fills in
where you think you can improve over the
Pito front so if you have no samples in
a region but you think you've modeled it
well and then you don't sample there
ever okay so there are two separate
things I'm thinking about here one is is
breaking this into a conditional so
instead of multiplying these two terms
and always biasing you towards the high
end of cost um you could do a local
Improvement for some samples and you
could do the global Improvement for
others so every time you take a global
sample right that's going to push the
maximum cost up for most environments
which then gives you more things to
sample with the local function but since
it's conservative it's not going to
really push the cost up until the uh
predictive model of cost gets to be or
of performance gets to be pretty good so
it's still rather
conservative um and it kind of balances
pushing up the cost with flushing out
the rest of the predo front if if I
modify the first
term and what the first term needs to do
I think the problem with this is that it
is right here it is the improvement over
your model of performance it's not your
improvement over actual data so
basically you're drawing a line in and
you're trying to make sure that you're
very confident about this line but you
don't actually fill in the points on the
line so let me show you what this looks
like in uh on real
data so right here we have score but if
we look at the Paro front for
this you see how there's this big gap
right here
and
here it doesn't it really it's pretty
darn confident that you know this is
0.91 and this is 099 and it's going to
be about a line you know from here to
here so it really doesn't feel obligated
to actually run the experiments to fill
the data in and that's not great because
that means we actually don't know what
hyper parameters are here I guess
technically we do have the gaussian
process so
like we could just assume the gaussian
process is good and we could fill in the
whole front just based on whatever the
gaussian process comes up
with that's an interesting
take oh actually you know what we should
totally do we should actually we should
totally do this we should do analysis on
the gaussian process of the hyper
parameter space as it's modeled it and
uh we should account for errors that's
going to be a lot of nice and is
actually that's a pretty darn nice
project to come to think of
it so we'll look into that later but
separately if I want to actually have
the if I actually want the whole parito
front to be filled
in do I want the whole Paro front filled
in
I guess in my mind I'm pretty confident
that it can do this
faster why am I confident that it can do
this
faster I have any reason to think it
should be able to do this
faster fre can connect four it shouldn't
be that
hard well I can also I can just see that
the it's really stopped exploring here
so the predictive model aren't going to
be that good so I'm actually I'm not
very confident in this parito front
essentially and basically it's giving
itself repeated training dat okay so I
see why I see why my intuition is that
this is bad yes you do want to actually
fill in the parito front otherwise your
predictive model will be worse so your
parito front will be inaccurate okay so
the way to do
this I think it's through this term here
so this is your estimate of how good you
can possibly do uh at a point on the
parito
front right so what if
right if I take the next point to the
right here and I say how much better do
you do than this point
you're never going to sample it because
this point is too far
away okay hold on
I can do this another
way if we were actually to draw the Pito
front
here right we can actually draw the
parito front it's defined just as the
set of points for which you can't do
both better and faster so it's like this
point here this point this point this
point this point this
point and I think that's it
so what if we were to find
find a point of a specific
cost and we try to find a cost that's
wherever the currently the biggest Gap
is in the Paro front
is the current approach somewhat similar
to constrain basing
optimization
um yeah it's a basing method it is the
current approach is carbs uh neoc carbs
really we've modified it quite
substantially it uses three different
Delian processes it's a cost aware
basian search where the goal is to well
on paper it's supposed to be a cost
Weare basing search doesn't really work
that way but the goal of the algorithm
is to model the Paro front so your goal
is to find the points for which you
cannot do both higher score in faster
time so they're like they're optimal in
that sense that no point is better in
both cost and time uh cost and
performance so this point this point
this point this point and this point are
the parito points uh for this experiment
so
far and the problem I'm addressing dring
at the moment is that this algorithm
likes to model the predo front without
actually filling it
in which is not
great I'd like it to actually fill in
the Frito front because the thing is the
model is likely to be wrong if it
doesn't actually fill in the front and
get the
feedback got 10 minutes to keep thinking
about this before this experiment over
here is
done and that's complicated
though okay so like
I guess what you try to do right is you
try to generate Pito points uh and you
decide if they're Paro based on your
model so you generate a whole bunch of
Paro
points
around I guess whatever Paro point is
nearest to the Gap
and then you rank them by how far away
they are from an existing Paro point in
terms of
cost trying to think of what like good
synthetic test I could come up with for
I think it's probably just give it a
really easy problem right if you okay
let's say you have a synthetic
hyperparameter test where the goal is
you what if the score function is
literally just
um time
spent right so you spend more time you
get more score
so like the tri like most trivial
possible optimization
problem and then what you do is you
basically you see how well the algorithm
fills in the front of
test let's do test hold
on oh um
uh I need my other window for
this we might not do this right
now we might come back to this because
this is done in six minutes let me just
see if I can walk
through what the uh the approach would
be so
Point based on the distance to the next
quickest or to the quicker to next
quicker Paro point so you score each of
them so for this one it's this distance
for this one it's uh this little
distance this one it's this
distance this distance this distance and
this distance okay and then you take the
max of
those so you take this
point right
here do you want this point or this
point
you probably want this
point okay so you score them on distance
to the next Point here and the one the
max point you uh you
exclude so you start from this point
here you generate your samples you're
going to generate you know a radius of
samples like
this let's say say right and then you're
going to generate those samples and uh
you're going to use your model to
estimate which of those samples you
think is going to be
Paro and then among this the parito
samples you take the one with the
highest predicted
cost not the highest predicted cost the
closest predicted cost to this point
here here which is between here and here
that's kind of a
complicated thing it's pretty easy to
code that up that's kind of a
complicated roundabout thing but it does
get you this
point but it does get you explicitly
trying to sample this point
so I guess which of these points are
Paro is the bad part here because none
of them might be parito
tricky we're kind of on to something
here though I like the idea of having
having samples to fill in the parito
front I also don't like the way that
carbs samples parito points
though cuz it samples randomly among the
parito points and you could have a ton
of clustered parito points
man there actually now that I'm thinking
about it there's so many details with
carbs that could quite obviously be
improved even after what I've done with
it I think what we're going to have to
do is we're going to have to I mean this
is going to have to be something I put
some time into so you know I got some
clients to deal with I got labs to deal
with I got a bunch of stuff to deal with
for the next few days but um you know
sometime in the next couple of weeks I
think I'm going to just have to set
aside a few days make a really nice
synthetic Benchmark and test all of
these things out like we want something
that fills in the Paro
front that only explores the higher cost
region on it's it's confident that the
results are going to be good so
basically we don't want this point here
shouldn't
exist this point shouldn't exist this
point shouldn't exist we should never
have EXP expensive experiments that are
bad you can have cheap experiments that
are bad but you should never have
expensive experiments that are
bad uh except in environments that are
like naturally very very high variant
where the same set of hyper parameters
can be good one trial bad the
next then it's kind of
okay yeah we're going to have to try all
this stuff out I'm really optimistic
here though because I'm actually like
it's clicking you know I'm seeing all
the different things that you want your
hyper pram algorithm to do I'm seeing
how they're really AB just not covered
At All by any existing
algorithm
um and there my experiment is done so
we'll go look at that but yeah it's
there's going to be a lot to think about
here it's pretty exciting it's pretty
exciting let me see so where's my
okay
95 it's about what we expect
here goal
achieved and we're going to go eval this
oh
oh okay so this is our experiment
file and we're going to go
into
examples eval
config eval config
now model
conf put this here and we're going to
see how good this model
is so one to
be run
I'm a new user to stream sorry does
search
radius in the paper and force that you
explore that front in a local search way
possibly avoiding diving to high clost
solution so quickly yes so to look at
the paper here they have this pearch
term um which keeps you close to your
existing Paro points but this is a very
very bad way of doing uh this search
because you really you don't want to
stick close to your existing points
right for no reason you only want to
stay close to your existing too points
when you're not confident in your
ability to explore so what I did is I
replaced this P search term with using
gpy I get an absolute estimate of
performance so what is the score that
your point is going is is going to get
and I subtract the standard deviation of
that prediction so I get a conservative
estimate of absolute score so what that
will do is that will slowly push you to
higher cost regions uh higher
performance regions which may have
higher cost but only as you're confident
in those predictions because you get
penalized by the standard deviation of
the prediction you get penalized for the
lack of confidence in your prediction so
that's what I've done so far uh I've
done a few other changes as well it does
massively better than the original you
know there's going to be a new algorithm
it's going to be neoc carbs and it's
going to be amazing for RL but it still
needs a little bit more you know I'm not
fully satisfied with it it's better it's
massively better it's not perfect yet
it's got some
quirks so we're still going to work on
that in between all the other stuff I'm
doing welcome YouTube folks going back
and forth here between now we hit 10 uh
10 viewers on stream awesome um yeah I'm
going back and forth between this hyper
parameter tuning stuff and then GPU
Drive nyu's GPU accelerated driving
simulator uh which I'm trying to
massively accelerate for them so that
they can run lots of cool experiments
very quickly and let's
see see I've been having some
trouble
78%
78 let's run the full set at the very
least I don't know how it gets
78 there's like this huge gap between um
what I'm seeing in training and what I'm
seeing
I mean the curve is really volatile to
be
fair also are they taking account the
um hold on they're they're penalizing me
a few agents here for no reason because
this should
be this is not controlled agents per is
okay no this is correctly implemented
they're not penalizing
me and that's the performance should be
higher than in training if you're
removing the bugged
this is very
odd this Gap is like almost entirely
unexplained I really don't know where
this would come
from so I have these curves right and uh
the latest curve is trained on a
thousand
scenes you can see this is the curve
here gets up
to oh 95% I should edit that message
5% so it gets
95% but then when I evalid on the exact
same scenes it only gets
78 it doesn't make sense to
me let me see if there's anything else
in here that would tell us what's going
on
so
coverage it's probably in
percentage new files in
batch coverage okay you can see these
are all
good metrics are
low let me see if I have um their
experiments to compare
to they sent me some of their
experiments
showing
ah want be so
slow so here's some of
their we'll use this one yeah this one's
good so they
metrix okay we have the same thing here
and then mean reward
89 this is this what it looks
yeah it's about what it looks like their
access is out to here so yeah that's
about what it looks
like mean agent we don't have speed
logged everything else is
logged episode
length interestingly it goes way down
and then it goes back up
similar I wonder if they have a
checkpoints committed for
this maybe they do hold on maybe they
have checkpoints
unfortunately
files
code oh wait they do have
checkpoints that's
okay so they
have this
seven so if this is 5 million
steps then I want to evaluate this
why does
this excuse
so presumably this is uh
not curling correctly or
4K okay so this is
wrong
um can I just copy this on the
not oh
I I see I
think yeah okay I see um that's
weird I guess that's the internal
structure I didn't know
Zips um
it why does this not work this always
works this is so
silly usually you can just curl
up so obnoxious um how do I get this
onto the
container
uh oh wait there I can just dock or CP
it I'm
dumb yeah that's stupid I can totally
just offer CP it
longer than I would have liked
but
13 oh it's loading it wrong I'm pretty
sure hold
on loading it wrong
buff foret code assumes discrete or
multi-
discreete that will
be well yeah we have to add continuous
actions you have to add more stuff to
it you
what no idea what that
uh I don't know not a robot generally
eat food not
oil not try to go about
this well you just add it's like I added
multi- discreet Joseph who is
loads some screwy
here cuz now I can't get their models to
eval
yo Joseph what's up
who do who is
5m I don't know from the Twitter
handle
uh still doesn't freaking work what the
heck
that okay it's loading the freaking
Network wrong I don't know how
is
it I can't freaking tell I can't get
there n to eval
now
[Music]
um where is this
here where's dhany why are you working
at
wait I literally copied this from them
right so there's literally no
way hold
on I copied this from
them offer
wait it's in examples
external okay so they do have 1 192 for
hidden in here
man what are the odds that this
checkpoint actually does this poorly I
think that's close to random
though and 14 should be close to random
maybe they changed the architecture
since uh uploading it and it screwed
stuff up I don't
know maybe they got a custom
branches I don't know but this doesn't
this we knows training logs are an
optimistic
estimate solve multiple
okay they're sending me over a
checkpoint what the hell's wrong with
this oh
answers using a sta center from the
cluster data is slightly shuffled
does you're basically evaluating on a
different data set
H weird
they were processed on a different day
another
relevance don't worry about evaluating
my
this looks
like this looks like their
curve to me this looks like their
curve like very very closely
and8
yep I mean it's like very hard for me to
imagine I could have messed this up
somehow let me look their uh their
standard deviation
where is the darn
[Music]
thing let me
see so they
standard oh yeah their standard
deviation is
lower why is their standard deviation
that much
lower
higher okay so why the heck could that
happen
me look at their
worlds kique seems they got
five it's pretty close otherwise
hypers I resample a little less
frequently